these are some of the strongest fighters
in the entire world government each of
them possesses incredible physical
strength and power that allows the
government to rule over the entire one
piece world all of the government forces
are split into four organizations and
today we'll be explaining and ranking
the strongest fighters in each of these
groups also at the end of the video
we'll reveal who the absolutely
strongest World Government fighter is
and we better to start than with the
newly introduced seraphim you see the
seven Warlords of the sea were the
pirates that Ally with the world
government in exchange for immunity
however during the lovely Arc this group
was disbanded and isn't under the
government's orders anymore instead
they've been replaced with seraphim
special pacifista cyborgs created by Dr
Vega Punk these cyborgs are modeled
after the Seven original Warlords and
can also use their devil fruit Powers
even the seraphim modeled after the
Warlords with no devil fruits such as
jinbe or mihawk got a devil fruit power
from previously imprisoned pirates with
esaw getting Mr one's super suomi and s
shark getting Senor ping sweetu noi on
top of that they also have some of
lunarian DNA granting Them Wings and
accelerated growth so how strong are
these guys well from what we've seen so
far in the show they look at least as
strong as their warlord counterparts and
are much easier to control than Warlords
as they'll follow any order without a
question but the craziest thing is that
they're all still just children and when
they grow up they might even surpass The
Originals now we don't have that much
information about each of the seraphim's
individual ual strengths but considering
they were modeled after the Warlords it
would make sense to rank them according
to that this would make esaw mihawk's
clone the strongest sarim which makes
sense when you remember that he was
strong enough to scare Blackbeard and
later took combined hits from Luchi and
Luffy without taking any serious damage
okay esaw easily takes the first spot
among seraphim but is there anyone
stronger than him in the government's
next organization the cp0 cp0 is the
strongest intelligence agency among
Cipher Poole working directly underworld
Nobles kind of like the FBI or CIA in
the real world although many members of
this group are unknown we do know that
all former cp9 agents are currently a
part of the cp0 every member this agency
can use all six forms of rokushiki
superhuman martial arts that allow the
user to strengthen their body move super
fast or run midair Khalifa fukuro
kumadori bluno and Jabra are considered
to be the weaker fighters of this group
and we didn't see much of them after
they lost against the straw hatch at any
Lobby however CP Z's main Force consists
of top tier Fighters that can give even
the strongest Pirates a tough time first
is gika one of the world government's
finest assassins during the battle on
onigashima he was able to stop one of
Luffy's strongest attacks and ensure
that kaido would win all while having a
hole in his body from a previous battle
the next one is stucy the first
successful clone created by the science
group mads based on Buckingham stucy a
former member of the Rocks Pirates she
has the same strength and power is the
original suy and also has the ability to
suck blood from people by biting into
their skin similar to a vampire but cp0
has two more members that are even
stronger than her and one of them is
giraffe human Kaku Kaku got much
stronger since we last saw him during
Anis Lobby he learned hockey and even
managed to awaken his devil fruit on the
eggh head he finally got his rematch
against zodo and although the battle was
cut short he proved capable of holding
his own against him at least for a short
time still not even Kaku is the
strongest cp0 member as that title goes
to Rob Luchi Luchi started his training
to become a Cypher pole assassin when he
was only 6 years old and it was
immediately evident that he was on a
completely different level compared to
everyone else when he was 13 Luchi was
sent to deal with a hostage situation
where pirates captured 500 soldiers
during the mission he killed the entire
pirate crew and all 500 hostages all by
himself at some point in his life Luchi
ate the neon Neco noi model leopard and
joined the cp9 is the strongest member
the agency had ever had after Lucci's
loss against Luffy during the NIS Lobby
he was kicked out of Cipher pole but
eventually reinstated as a member of cp0
same as Kaku he also awakened his Z and
devil fruit and became much stronger
since the last time we saw him currently
on Egghead Luchi is fighting on equal
footing against zodo which is no small
feat and easily makes him the strongest
Cipher pole agent so far in the series
with the CP zero covered there were
still two government organizations that
hold immense power throughout the one
piece world and the final one may just
be the strongest of them all but before
we cover that one let's first cover the
biggest one the Marines although big in
numbers the Marines are full of weak men
with only Vice Admirals and above being
noteworthy the lower ranks like captains
and commanders don't even know hockey
and couldn't hope to compete with some
of the characters we'll talk about in a
minute this is why we'll put all lower
ranking Marines in F tier and vice
Admirals in etier now although the E
tier includes the big majority of Vice
Admirals it doesn't include all of them
because some are simply on a completely
different level and one of those is sudu
who has possibly the weirdest devil
fruit ability in the entire show sudu
was one of the legendary Marines of
rogers's era we know that she was
actively trying to capture doflamingo
back in the day with doflamingo being
terrified of her and always running away
instead of facing her head on sudu was
also shown to be very knowledgeable and
well- informed being the only one who
knew leit in his background when he
entered the warlord's meeting even
though she's been a marine for 56 years
and we were introduced to her all the
way back in chapter 234 we don't really
know anything else about her heck we
don't even know what her devil fruit
does it's called wosu wosu no me and
apparently allows her to wash and dry
her enemies like clothes sudu can also
wash evil out of her enemies using this
devil fruit which has got to be one of
the weirdest devil fruit abilities in
the one piece but let's continue the
list with another Legendary Marine the
fans are dying to learn more about Kong
before he got a promotion Kong was the
fleet Admiral during Rogers time meaning
he must be one of the world government's
strongest Fighters so what does this guy
currently do well Kong is now the world
government's commanderin-chief which
gives them authority over all the
Marines Cipher Poes and even Warlords
while there were still a thing since
both positions Kong was assigned to were
pretty much death jobs we unfortunately
never get to see him fight however
considering his important position in
Mighty appearance he has to be super
strong and I have a feeling he'll be
showing us his real strength sometime in
the final Saga for now C tier is a
Fitting Place for him and we can't talk
about the Marine Legends of the previous
generation without mentioning the former
Fleet Admiral sangoku sangoku joined the
Marines when he was 23 from there he
slowly climbed the ranks becoming an
admiral then the fleet Admiral and
finally Inspector General during this
time he also raised two pirates in
secret rosinante who later joined donot
Pirates as a spy and ex Drake who became
a member of the sword at some point in
his life he Acquired and ate the hitoo
noi model daibutsu a mythical zo and
devil fruit that allows him to turn into
a giant Golden Buddha during his prime
around 30 years ago sangoku was
considered one of the strongest Marines
often clashing with one piece Legends
like Roger and Whitebeard when Shiki
attacked Marine Ford 26 years ago
sangoku along with gar fought against
him in a battle that destroyed half of
the island imagine the damage of the
summit War but caused only by three
people yeah this dude was insane despite
being incredibly powerful sangoku is
also an excellent tactician in fact he
was the one in charge of deployment
positions of all the Marines during the
summit war and he even made a dirty plan
to have the pacifistas avoid attacking
the whitebeard's main crew in order for
it to look like Whitebeard sold out all
his allies when Blackbeard showed up to
the party we got to see that even years
later sangoku was still a very capable
fighter injuring Blackbeard's entire
crew with a single blow however even
with all that power sangoku is not even
in the top five of the strongest Marine
Fighters and of those strong longer than
him is Admiral greenbull sometime after
the time skip greenbull participated in
the world military draft where he was
appointed as one of the new Admirals due
to his strength and power this power
mostly comes from his incredible Loi a
devil fruit Mor noi which allows him to
turn into any type of plant life green
Bull's biggest Idol is the fleet Admiral
sakazuki and while he respects him a lot
he never seems to listen to him for
example when sakazuki ordered him to
stay away from wano he immediately went
to wano to prove himself and when he was
ordered to kick fujit TOA off Mary joa
he instead had a friendly chat with him
someone's getting fired soon however
despite acting like a child when it
comes to orders greenbull is actually a
phenomenal fighter he proved this when
he effortlessly defeated all the
remaining Beast pirates in minutes and
would surely defeat Yamato and Mos if
their battle wasn't interrupted after he
got humiliated by Shanks many fans have
been clowning on greenbull calling him a
fraud but come on let's be real here
Shanks would make absolutely anyone look
pathetic so we shouldn't judge green bow
too harshly who UJiT to is another
Admiral who joined the Marines during
the time skip after proving himself in
the world military draft and he is
without a doubt a complete opposite of
all the other current Admirals the first
thing you'll notice about fujit TOA is
that he is blind but you may be
surprised to find out that this isn't an
injury he suffered on the battlefield
you see after seeing so much evil in the
world Fuji TOA actually blinded himself
because he couldn't stand looking at
evil anymore however due to fujit TOA
being incredibly skilled in using
observation hockey this disability
doesn't seem to impact is fighting in
any way as he can still hold his own
against powerful opponents in addition
to his hockey Mastery fujit TOA also has
an incredible devil fruit called Zushi
Zushi noi which allows him to control
gravity using it fujit to can pin his
opponents to the ground repel incoming
attacks and even bring down meteors from
space the interesting thing is that this
makes fujit to the only non lokia
Admiral in the series but that's not the
only way he's different from the rest of
them you see Fuji to doesn't believe
that all the Marines are good and that
all Pirates are evil instead he always
does what he thinks is Right which led
him to pissing off sakazuki more than
once man he and greenbull are basically
competing to see who will get fired
first since his introduction fujit to
participated in many fights he briefly
fought against law doflamingo Sabo zodo
Luffy and even against greenbull when
they had a disagreement however none of
these were serious allout fights meaning
Fuji to's true strength is still unknown
Admiral kizaru kizaru may seem very
relaxing laidback most of the time but
he may actually be one of the most
serious Marines in the Navy I mean I
doubt many others would stay quiet when
ordered to kill their good friend like
isatu did but let's start from the
beginning isatu was originally
introduced in chapter 506 and he had one
of the most badass entrances in the
entire series first he casually rode on
top of a cannonball and then
effortlessly defeated four supernovas
whose combined Bounty was
777 million berries even when the dark
King reallyy jumped into stop kizu he
couldn't really do anything but briefly
stall the Admiral the reason kizu is so
strong is mostly due to his absurdly
powerful devil fruit pika pika no me
which allows him to turn into and
control light in addition to standard
lokia abilities kizu can pretty much
travel at light speed teleport to any
desired location or even blind his
enemies as far as we know in his 32
years of being a marine kizo has never
taken a hit that seriously damaged him
however this recently changed during the
Egghead arc when he finally clashed with
Luffy and pretty much got paralyzed by
Luffy's punch during this Arc kizu also
showed how seriously he takes his Marine
duties when he agreed to kill Dr Vap
Punk his old friend whom he had known
for many years this incredible loyalty
towards the Marines coupled with his
immense power makes kiz worthy of the a
tier but we can't talk about the
Admirals without mentioning a guy whose
strength is easily on bar with theirs
the hero of the Marines GARP GARP joined
the Marines at the age of 22 and quickly
ascended through the ranks due to his
incredible physical strength eventually
becoming the vice admiral during his
prime GARP was widely recognized as one
of the strongest fighters of his time
being the number one rival of the pirate
king and almost catching him quite a few
times however what really made Garb
famous was the god Valley incident where
he teamed up with Roger in order to take
down rockd zebic a famous pirate who
wanted to conquer the world after that
GARP gained the epithet hero of the
Marines and became somewhat of a symbol
around the world now you may me
wondering if GARP was really without
famous and Powerful why did he never
become an admiral well you see GARP was
actually offered this position on
multiple occasions but instantly refused
each time this is because the Admirals
are under the direct control of the
world Nobles or as GARP calls them
scumbags and have to protect them
whenever they're in danger this
obviously wasn't something GARP wanted
to do so he just continued being the
vice admiral and pretty much did
whatever the hell he wanted this
Carefree attitude is what eventually got
him in big trouble in the recent
chapters when he decided to attack
Blackbeard's base of operations in order
to save Kobe although he eventually
succeeded in put up a great fight
against former Admiral aliji he was
eventually injured and defeated by the
combined efforts of Blackbeard's crew
for now GARP is declared missing an
action the fleet Admiral sakazuki due to
something that happened in his past
sakazuki started believing in absolute
Justice which pretty much means that he
believes that evil should be eradicated
from the world at any cost even if it
involves innocent deaths or immoral acts
with this belief sakazuki joined the
Marines 32 years ago and quickly became
one of the world government's favorites
due to his absolute loyalty at some
point in his life sakazuki ate the
magumagu noi a loia type devil fruit
that allows him to transform into magma
this is undoubtedly one of the strongest
devil fruits in the entire series and
when coupled with sakazuki immense
strength it's easy to see why he's so
feared and respected around the world
due to his Feats sakazuki was eventually
promoted to the rank of Admiral and got
the nickname aahu which literally
translates to Red Dog this is a pretty
fitting nickname for him considering
he's pretty much a world government's
dog dog who does their bidding for them
however it's important to mention that
he does oppose the government's views
sometimes and is not afraid to even
insult them but he always ends up
following the orders in the end the best
Showcase of sakazuki strength as an
admiral was during the summit War where
he Gravely injured Whitebeard and easily
overpowered many strong Fighters such as
jimbe and Ace when the former Fleet
Admiral sangoku declared that he would
be retiring from his position and
recommended aiji as a successor the
world government was quick to act and
recommend Ayu instead this led to a
fierce battle between between the two
Admirals that lasted for 10 full days
with sakazuki eventually emerging
Victorious although getting promoted was
what he wanted he does seem a bit
regretful about it as all he does now is
sit at his desk and give orders instead
of going out to fight Pirates himself
hopefully this will soon change as I
can't wait to see him in action again
okay it's pretty obvious that sakazuki
is currently the strongest marine
officer in the story but there's still
one more organization left to cover with
characters that are possibly even
stronger than him Mary choa Fighters
this obviously isn't the organization's
real name but I needed to somehow
separate Fighters that live on the Holy
Land Mary joa and aren't the members of
any group we've covered so far the First
characters in this group are recently
introduced Gods Knights who are the
guards of the holy land from what we've
seen so far they seem to be way more
important than the Marines and it looks
like they even have authority over
normal Celestial dragons this is
absolutely insane as even the fleet
admiral has absolutely no control over
the world Nobles and often has to endure
their insults the one in charge of the
Gods Knights is St figland Garling who
happens to be a Celestial Dragon himself
which could also be the case for all the
other Knights although we can't know for
sure the true strength of the Gods
Knights is currently unknown but looking
at dragon's reaction when he mentioned
them they seem to be an incredibly
powerful group of Fighters so at this
point you may be wondering what do these
characters actually do don't the
Admirals in the Navy already protect the
celestial dragons well yes but think of
the Gods Knights as the law enforcers of
the Holy Land pretty much acting as the
police for the celestial dragons for
example we've seen that that figure lent
has the power to judge and if needed
kill other Celestial dragons if they
break the rules although we don't know
much about the gods knights we know that
the majority of them were present at God
Valley 38 years ago and when Roger
attacked the island they quickly
assembled to fight him proving just how
much confidence they have in their
abilities we obviously can't separately
rank Gods Knights as we still don't know
enough about them so I'll put them all
in B tier why only B tier well it'll be
pretty obvious once you see how strong
the other Mary joa Fighters are the five
Elders the five Elders are five
Celestial dragons who have the highest
Authority in the entire one piece world
this means that they have the power of
Cipher poles the Marines the seraphim
and most likely the gods Knights as well
many people are completely unaware of
their existence which isn't that
surprising considering they rarely leave
their room in the Pangia Castle the
interesting thing about them is that in
all the flashbacks they've appeared in
they look exactly the same which led
many people to believe that they're
actually Immortal and have been alive
for a long long time the most popular
Theory so far is that they achieved this
by by using ope op noi a devil fruit
that's known to have the power to Grant
someone eternal life since the very
beginning of the show the elders were
thought to be just politicians without
any fight in them but that proved to be
completely false during recent chapters
when all Elders transformed into demonic
creatures in order to attack Sabo
although we don't know anything else
about the majority of the elders we did
actually learn about St Saturn on
Egghead Island and we even got to fully
see his demonic form when transformed
Saturn looks like a gigantic spider-like
creature with horns resembling one of
the yo-kai from Japanese mythology in
this form Saturn can project some kind
of invisible force when invoking this
power his eyes start to glow and Saturn
can injure people with a mere look
unfortunately we still don't have enough
information to accurately judge Saturn's
strength but based on what we've seen so
far and considering that these guys are
supposed to be one of the show's main
antagonists Saturn and his fellow Elders
must be incredibly powerful putting them
in a tier however there's one character
in the world government who holds even
more power than the five elders and
that's the the secret ruler of the world
emu emu is one of the biggest mysteries
in the show right now and nobody is
allowed to know of their existence
except for the five Elders although not
confirmed emu is suspected to be one of
the original 20 creators of the world
government who lived 800 years ago and
has somehow survived to this day in
addition to controlling the five elders
and the whole world government emu holds
the power to make the whole islands
disappear Without a Trace whether it's
some kind of devil fruit power he uses
to do this or just a weapon remains to
be seen now if this emu is the same Emu
from the void Century 800 years ago it
must mean that they also had an
immortality operation done on them with
the op op noi similar to the five Elders
although we've only seen emu a couple of
times in the show they seem to be
particularly interested in Luffy
Blackbeard Shah hosi and Vivie but we
have no idea what connects those four
specifically as we already said Eno's
existence is top secret and everyone who
finds out about him will be immediately
executed this is exactly what happened
to King Cobra as the five Elders told
him the moment he saw emu his fate was
sealed but same as all other characters
on this list emu is not just a
politician or a figurehead he's also
seemingly a devil fruit user who can
transform into a huge shadowy monster in
this form emu was shown capable of
controlling some kind of sharp shadowy
arrows that can easily penetrate even
loia users like Sabo besides this not
much is known about emu's abilities but
considering how they will most likely be
the last obstacle on the straw Hat's
journey I think we can all agree that
emu goes into the S tier and takes the
top spot as the world government's
strongest fighter since you obviously
like power scaling you can click on this
video next where we rank the top 15
strongest swordsman in one piece